[Musique]
park
il n'a pas réussi six homogène du puits
alors cette semaine ma chronique est
inspiré par une émission banquette qui a
fait ressortir des déclarations de jean
chrétien notre ancien premier ministre
autour de ce cadre est en train de se
découvrir
du fait qu' il y à des politiques contre
et de l'obscur du lobbying qui se fait
autour de créer au québec tout
particulièrement à ce que j'ai compris
au labrador des sites d'enfouissement de
déchets toxiques mais qu'ils ne viennent
pas de cet axe excusez mon radioactifs
mais qu'ils ne viennent pas du canada
qui aimeraient bien étrange et toute la
sphère bien on peut comprendre me tient
à coeur aimant braz mais c'est
particulièrement la déclaration que
monsieur chrétien fait en disant bien
oui peut-être avoir des problèmes
d'indiscipliné là mais on laisse le
relief des policiers diffusion s'en
occuper c'est comme on n'y pense pas se
mettre dans dix mille ans et vous
comprendrez que la réflexion engagée
j'en ai souvent parlé dans les
chroniques c'est lé cette future
génération comment est ce qu'on peut
faire ce genre de déclaration là on
regarder cette future génération et des
impacts des choix des québécois et
canadien aujourd'hui en 2020 par rapport
à la future génération par rapport à
l'avenir pourquoi je voulais parler
particulièrement parce que je pense
souvent ces temps-ci de l'économie du
web 10 go pour ceux qui connaissent pas
le windigo on l'appelle aussi la chaîne
c'est un monstre mythique qui existe
dans la cosmogonie des communautés
autochtones et wendy go en chine c'est
un être humain parce qu'elle est libre
ou des gens qui n'y aurait que c'était
bien cru mais au début qui s'est
transformé en monstres cannibales et les
décrit de façon très horrible parce
qu'il a fait un des tabous que les plus
importants et c'est celui de manger de
la chair humaine
alors c'est tellement ce cannibale et
certaines histoires de acino goût de
wendy go on justement même le volet de
la mer qui mange ses enfants
imaginez que pour les communautés
autochtones c'est à peu près la pire
l'histoire la pire sorte qu'on peut se
résorber
mais c'est un sort qu'on se fait à soi
même quand au départ c'est le naturel
qu'on ne respecte pas justement
l'équilibré qui existe dans la nature
c'est à dire de prendre des ressources
d'être aussi une ressource qui va se
donner
donc on veut étirer sa vie parce que ça
se passe en famine que ces histoires se
racontent
on étire sa vient en mangeant ses
propres enfants et aujourd'hui
l'économie capitaliste tel qu'on l'a en
roulant promu parce qu'il ya des
versions de capitalistes qui peuvent
être une économie équilibrée mais là on
parle de capitalisme en 2021
c'est une forme d'économie de wendy
gohelle mangent les ressources
nécessaires aux futures générations à
nos enfants de pouvoir exister survivre
sur le territoire dit si justement aller
10 mai les dix mille années que monsieur
chrétien nos nez et vous comprendrez que
quand on a cette responsabilité le
regard là vers nos enfants nos
petits-enfants
on peut pas se permet de faire des
projets d'autonomie comme ceux qui sont
proposés
ils sont tous comme tres tres puisque
les attaques ne se feront pas dit si tu
de trois élections et c'est vraiment
comment on évalue des projets comment on
se donne le droit faire des projets
c'est de voir les impacts sont ils pour
moi mes enfants mes petits enfants
possédaient j'y pense plus faut
comprendre que pour des nations qui
habitent les mêmes territoires depuis
des milliers d'années
c'est impensable d'accepter ce genre de
projet là probablement que la réflexion
se fait pas la même manière quand on a
voyagé beaucoup qu'on me coloniser
d'autres territoires
et quand on voit la capacité de fuir un
territoire comme étant une solution pour
les innu qui sont des milliers d'années
je pense pas que furent le territoire
est une solution viable et une solution
qui est désirable dans l'économie de
wendy go dans la
la réflexion qu'on ne veut le faire il
faut vraiment commencer à voir comment
s'est passé le ont un impact est une
réalité aussi parce qu'on pensait d'eux
dit lula si tout va bien mais qu'est ce
qu'on parle de tête dans dix ans si tout
va mal et on a vu beaucoup de ces
projets d'enfouissement mal tourné on a
vu beaucoup de projets énergétiques mal
se concevoir vouloir couper les coins
ronds pour pouvoir économiser et faire
augmenter les profits donc on doit avoir
le devoir de transformer l'économie de
transformer la vision justement de ce
que l'économie est aujourd'hui et
d'empêcher peut-être des générations qui
ont malheureusement se sont fait dire
que les grammy du wendigo c'était les
conneries qu'il fallait favoriser et
peut-être commencer à décoloniser nos
formes d'économie pas seulement en tant
qu'autochtones mais aussi en tant que
citoyen du territoire donc vous
comprendrez que cela est une question
d'avenir que c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut qu'on discute et j'espère que vous
n'hésiterez pas à partager cette
chronique et non plus à la partager
les autres ressources parce qu'on peut
maintenant les trouver en podcast
alors je souhaite une bonne semaine